maître patrick gluckman est avec nous
merci merci d'être avec nous parce que
c'est là sur l'émission talk show qui
fait vous avez fait bfm et vous avez
choisi de venir vous exprimer dans
touche pas à mon poste je sais que vous
avez regardé l'émission hier avec
l'avocat des parents de yann moix et de
son frère et je sais qu'aujourd'hui vous
voulez réagir alors déjà la première
question que j'ai envie de vous poser
c'est dans quel état d'esprit et yann
moix aujourd'hui parce que c'est vrai
qu'hier on a remontré des extraits d' on
n'est pas couché
et voilà il y en avait il ya certains
qui disait qu'il était sincère d'autres
noms d'autres qu'il était très affecté
il est dans quel état d'esprit
aujourd'hui yann moix iliad mois ci dans
un état d'esprit très particulier comme
quelqu'un qui vivait ce livre comme une
libération comme une expiation et ils
savaient qu'en racontant les douleurs de
l'enfance le reste allait sortir
yann moix est un homme qui vit avec des
maîtres chanteurs d'un genre un peu
particulier qui disent n'oublie pas on
était copains on ne lâchera pas yann
moix a changé n'a cessé de dénoncer
certaines idées et certains d'idées
qu'il a fréquentée qui l'a tutoyé par
détestation probablement de lui même
mais cette immonde fait partie de lui et
c'est de cela dont il s'est extrait donc
c'est quelqu'un qui avait l'assentiment
de d'une renaissance puisque naissance
est un de ces livres qui a assisté à sa
mort à sa volonté de mort cathodique qui
ne s'est pas exprimé depuis huit dix
jours sur yann moix certains vraime
certains parents souhaitant qu'il se
taise qu'il disparaisse kilmer qui ne
soit jamais n'est qu'ils ne soient pas
écrit main donc c'est quelqu'un une des
rares personnes qui assistent à sa vie à
sa mort de manière figurer d'une manière
un peu excessive
hier hier l'avocat des parents yann moix
et du fresnoy que disait qu'il ne disait
pas la vérité
il présente au livre comme un roman il
dit qu'il aimerait voilà que ian white
avoue que c'est un roman et remet en
question toute la véracité de ses propos
sur les sévices qu'il a pu subir
lorsqu'il était plus jeune vous avant
qu'on est là la réponse de l'avocat est
ce que vous vous sentez victime coupable
il ya deux mois et géraldine maillet moi
je suis d'accord avec avec ce que vous
dites savoir qu'il ya un tribunal
médiatique qui se goinfrent aujourd'hui
sur le monstre télévisuelle qui est
devenu yann moix
mais pour autant ne pensez vous pas
qu'il est d'abord coupable d'avoir
transformé ce roman
formidable en télé réalité obscène ne
pensez vous pas qu'il est coupable
d'avoir dessiné des dessins donc
antisémite et révisionniste quand il
avait 16 22 ans
ne pensez vous alors des coupables
d'avoir tergiversé en disant non non non
je n'ai pas écrit comme l'avait rappelé
hier valérie et finalement avoir écrit
ne pensez-vous géraldine géraldine on se
concentre là ce soir
sur ce qu'il a dit dans le livre voilà
sur les sévices qu'il a pu subir on se
concentre la tuile mais ça peut être un
révisionniste familial aussi où il va
dire que battu enfin battu par enfant
battu bon fils nommé chief est ce qu il
est un fils unique
les deux choses sont extrêmement
importantes et je voudrais pas en vous
répondant escamoté ce que vous nous dire
ce que vous voulez la question du mas
est posée si la nonna elle est
essentielle parce que il y a dans le
livre au coeur du livre une affaire de
maltraitance oui maintenant une affaire
d'enfance battue c'est l'enfance de yann
moix
d'abord je crois que chacun chacun
d'entre nous un droit supérieur c'est
celui de se raconter
mais vous vous rendez compte si pour une
polémique que le frère à amis niçois
place publique des dessins antisémites
de yann moix qui sont assumés on vient à
remettre la violence subie et donc on
aurait essayé à l'occasion de gad moix à
l'occasion de son livre son enfance ça
serait une magnifique opportunité pour
un père violent de dire bah finalement
non je ne suis qu'en finlande aurait et
c'est à cela qu'on a pas et pardon il ya
au au coeur de cette histoire une
affaire de maltraitance s'habille vial
depuis quand et dans quelle affaire qui
at on vu comme père violent et
maltraitant se précipiter et dire oui
c'est vrai j'ai tabassé mon fils moi je
vous dis et yann moix attendez je
vénérais deux questions celle à faire
dit que c'était faux oui oui son frère
dit que c'était faux mais nous on allait
on a des preuves que ces vraies preuves
sortiront et je veux dire pourquoi parce
que ce procès que tout le monde attend
c'est nous qui allons le faire et ça
sera un débat contradictoire en données
dont ils avaient attaqué la famille bien
sûr parce que nous n'avons plus le choix
mais ce que je veux dire par là c'est
que la maltraitance familiale elle ne
peut pas être occultée et jeu
il ya un point qui ne peut pas être
discutée
et yann moix n'a pas menti yann moix n'a
jamais menti
ah non pardon excusez moi bien sûr que
s'il a menti par oui et bien menti jeudi
à la mémoire démontré après moi que ça
n'a pas menti
on lui a mis en face des dessins
monsieur avez-vous fait ses dessins il
dit oui non non je bats on attend que je
veux bien qu'on parle tous en même temps
et battre l'usap ans est concluante plus
fort vous a raison sur moi vous gagnerez
en télé j'aimerais rappeler les faits
ils sont un petit peu complexe on va
dans l'appareil avec the wrestler allait
bien donc l'express sera premier article
oui ils interrogent yann moix et yann
moix dix mois dans cette publication qui
s'appelait ushuaïa mais qui est déjà en
soi une abomination
j'ai fait des dessins et je n'ai pas
écrit dès que les textes
derrière il y a une collection de textes
qui ressorte dont le journaliste de
l'express
arnaud dupuis as possession jérôme
jérôme dupuis perdants et ils le
réinterroge yann moix et yann moix dit
une chose qui est sa vérité à lui
d'écouter les dessins ils sont
inextricables des textes dans une
publication
je ne peux pas dire je ne peux pas dire
que je suis extérieurs à ces textes
oui je ne peux pas dire que je n'ai rien
à voir les textes sont immondes les
excuses mais les créations qui monde les
dessins sont connus je n'aime pas
reconnu dans un premier temps être
l'auteur des textes mois s'est noyé à
son tour par don qui aurait consacré
même à la faire revenir là dessus il ya
toujours reconnu être l'auteur des
dessins et il a assumé les textes et en
imax trick ablement liés l'express a
écrit il a menti et libération il écrit
d'avancé vous plaît m j'aimerais qu'on
s'intéresse dans le livre voilà dans le
livre où il dit qu'il a été victime de
sévices ses parents disent que c'est
faux son frère dit que c'est lui qui a
été la victime de yann moix eric
naulleau je vais vous dire pourquoi je
crois yann moix
allez-y voilà c'est la croix-rouge à
yann moix parce que seule une enfance
martyrs peut expliquer je ne dis pas
excusé mais jeudi expliqué que quelqu'un
se réfugie dans une pareille négativité
et dans des délires antisémites et
négationnistes sa jeune vie d'enfant ce
martyr qu'il a écrit dans un livre ne
dit pas je me permets une alim de
serviable je perdrais pas retourner
contre lui et là je l'aimais remila il
laisse le joueur me dites pas que dans
tous les cas ça s'exprime comme ça mais
je crois qu'il n'y a un rapport très
fort entre une enfance martyrs et ce
délire de négativité donc sur cette base
je crois que yann moix dit vrai ou en
tout cas dit en grande partie vrai donc
les deux affaires sont quand même lié
mais j'en ai mon point de vue m vous dit
quelque chose qui est très très fort a
priori que vous avez des preuves que
c'était à l'ouest qui étaient victimes
de maltraitance pénaliser les preuves
dit que les maintenant à quoi ça sert de
laisser cette merde se répandre partout
d'un titre maintenant à quoi ça sert
bâton a brossé
je vous dis l'épreuve les choses elles
seront produites pendant le lieu
approprié pour voir tribunal que vous
n'en avez pas dit le matin 16 de la
sphère s'arrête
excusez moi monsieur léger vous ils vous
me donnez raison d'avoir quasiment
refusé tous les débats télévisuels
on a laissé tout le monde et les
questions simples et d'ailleurs
maintenant d'ailleurs n'est-ce pas ce
que vous voulez yann moix en publiant un
livre maintenance je constate que c'est
la seule personne en france et peut-être
mon monsieur et je vous regarde droit
dans les yeux vous 10 ans qui se dit
victime d'une violence et la france
entière s'interroge
moi je dis qu'il n'a pas vraiment été
victimes de violences c'est le premier
droit d'une personne c'est quand même de
se dire de raconter une souffrance que
l'on a enduré en l'occurrence dans sa
chair avec des sévices qui ont laissé
des traces il est tragique et des traces
biologiques le gardon cyril hanouna
vous disiez moix victime ou coupable
mois pour le connaître et pour le
regarder mais ça là dessus je pense que
chacun en est témoin je dirais que moi
que c'est avant tout son propre bourreau
c'est quelqu'un qui se fait mal mais il
se fait mal pour une raison c'est un
gamin évidemment qui a été tabassé et
fracassé et je vous creux je revendique
ici le droit supérieur qu'à chacun quand
il a subi sa de le dit
donné qu'en annonçant que soient traités
avec légèreté mais par agathe victime
coupable parce que chermat ce n'est pas
nous ni le public ni les anonymes qui
mettons en paroles qui mettons en doute
le livre et la parole de yann moix et
son propre frère jordan raconte une
autre version de l'histoire est mon ami
l'auteur des faits présumés
les reconnaître condamnée mais en quoi
est ce que la parole de la droite
devrait prévaloir sur celle de son frère
qui raconte exactement les mêmes sévices
on a le droit de se poser la question de
savoir qui dit la vérité on en est
justement sur l'instant on a dans le
récit qui s'est offert devant nos yeux
l'histoire d'une double vengeance
familiale il y a un frère resté proche
des parents il y a des parents accusés
de violences et très classiquement il y
a un parent qui vole au secours des
parents mais ce n'est pas un enfant qui
a été battu lui aussi et donc il dit et
c'est très perverse que fait le frère il
dit en fait le les violences dont yann
moix se dit la victime c'est moi qui ai
subi de sa part et ça c'est une
substitution absolument monstrueuse et
c'est pour cette raison-là cela nous là
parce qu'à un moment on n'a plus le
choix que nous allons porter cette cette
histoire devant un tribunal dans un
temps serein dans un temps où il y aura
plus d'accusations de promotion dans un
huis clos où on pourra s'expliquer et où
chacun sera face enfin alors je vous dis
ah bon avant qu'on ait la vie on a
recueilli les confidences exclusives
d'un ami d'enfance de yann moix qu'ils
étaient ensemble à l'école primaire à
orléans il se souvient notamment
regarder que le père de yann moix que
c'était impressionnant et tri est très
autoritaire regarder son père m'a
toujours impressionné
j'ai un souvenir de son père qui surgit
dans le pas sur le parking qui vient
attraper son fils avec une forme de
physiquement il vient de le choper en
disant il faut rentrer voilà
c'est un peu millions j'imagine pour lui
les avec son copain ils jouent tout se
passe bien et puis d'un seul coup il une
espèce de truc qui surgit comme ça le
truc un peu violent on sentait que
c'était sans sommation ce rapport du
père au fils moi j'ai passées à la
maison
alors moi je trouve près pervers m
pardon c'est d'avoir évincé totalement
le frère son frère du roman voilà moi
moi je les fais j'ai écrit ma vie dans
un roman aussi voilà un roman d
autofiction
je n'ai éluder aucun fait j'ignorais
caves et des rez comme on joue alors ils
sont prêts on a posé la question
justement un ami d'enfance donc de yann
moix aux mêmes amis d'enfance et puisque
alexandre moix a accusé son frère d'être
son bourreau et il a du mal à croire à
cette histoire
regardez bien nous parlait jamais de son
frère je ne comprends pas qu'on puisse
dire qu'il était un bourreau que c'était
quelqu'un d'affreux et c'est parce que
avec ses camarades de classe et dans sa
façon de vivre etc
il n'y avait rien de majeur enfin qui
transparaissait et qui pouvait nous
laisser penser que c'était quelqu'un de
méchant de durs etc
m goodman je mets date déjà
effectivement y at il des règles du
roman vous avez fait une oeuvre qui vous
concerne qui faisait personnel auriez
vous supportez monsieur que l'on vous
dise ce que vous devez faire comment
vous devez les mais vous avez ma mère
pour lui dire je vais aller dévaler
droit et personne n'avait le droit sur
terre de le dire et comment le faire et
comment vous en êtes maître renard n'a
pas été suivi
moix est décidé de se raconter et les
vieux ne menace pas regarder ce que tu
as vu la manière dont il entend aussi
une manière pardon eric naulleau et je
sais que nous sommes sur le fond
d'accord à dire de se raconter de
raconter son intime dans quelle société
vivons nous verrons où allons nous vous
êtes sur coup deux c'est là où vous
voulez aller voir l'argument d'eric
naulleau serait en france le seul enfant
battu on dit attention c'est que même si
le faire attention aux droits de la
défense je suis sensible moi je veux une
simple question oui dans une virée au
hong kong célèbre tristement les
violences faites aux femmes on va aller
voir à chaque fois les mecs qui disent
banon si la sphère était aussi clair
s'il était certain que yann moix n'ai
jamais subi de sévices pourquoi avoir
ont brouillé la sphère en révélant les
dessins et les des textes antisémites
voilà pourquoi ça a été balancée à
cabaye à la notion de mettre un état
faible a été balancé par sa famille
puisque j'ai tu as créé de yann moix qui
est que son frère aurait balancé les
hommes ou alors c'est pour vous mais
évidemment c'est faux puisque le journal
et gyan dupuis justement avec les
documents et voulait joindre alexandre
mois et avec qui je tenais les avait pas
les chômeurs non seulement pas les
chronos moi ce qu'ils savaient pas
comment le joindre
alors avec un peu près d'am on a posé
une troisième question avait choqué on a
posé une troisième question est l'ami
d'enfance de yann moix et au sujet des
signes de maltraitance et regarder ce
qui n'était pas super motivé de partir
de l'école et de rentrer chez lui
on sentait que t'es pas pressés de
rentrer était nerveux il était un petit
que comme on dit un peu avait des
moments un peu comme ça sentait qu'il y
avait un truc qui avait besoin de sortir
quand même mais pardon à dire un mot
parce que pardon bête parce que vous
parlez beaucoup
et voilà et vous parlez bien mais je ne
connais ni haine moix ni son frère
pourquoi je devrais croire yann moix
parce qu'elle est connue parce qu'ils
aient les moyens d'avoir un avocat parce
qu'il parle bien et qu'il a tout tout
tout tout les gens autour de lui et tout
l'intellectuel a été bien bien pensante
autour de lui pourquoi je veux croire
mais pourquoi je devrais en croit un
plus que l'autre d'autant que vous dites
j'ai des preuves qu'on montrera très
bien mais je pourrais dire l'inversé au
contraire aussi genre montre aucune
pourquoi je devrais le croirez-vous
époux de monsieur non l'enceinte
judiciaire
moi je crois effectivement que la
présomption qui doit toujours prévaloir
et je le dis sur un plateau télé
évidemment la présomption d'innocence
dakota recevrez un autre cadre ce soir
et depuis la sortie de ce livre nous
sommes en quelqu'un qui raconte une vie
de souffrance et une enfance de
souffrance et je crois que la
présomption doit bénéficier à celui qui
se raconte en mettant en cause son frère
disant que son frère du nord pour la
même voulu le copier tout faire et comme
dit que c'était quelqu'un
les autres mis en cause ses parents
d'avoir subi des sévices et c'est son
frère qui a décidé lui d'opéra d'opérer
cette crapuleuses et abracadabrantesque
population de substitution bourque et
ses droits à lumio vous a dit jeudi que
chacun a maintenant va assumer ce que
vous allez mes proches je revendique
pour yann moix vous à l'euro qu'à chacun
de se raconter comme victimes le droit
dess de ne pas être le seul enfant battu
de france dont 10 à 15 m en façade
arrière vous avez rien vous dire qu'il
va avec le boys band de le croire mais
la vraie vie mais ce n'est pas rapport
tire est toujours amer je vous demande
sat 1 hd
je vous demande de l'entendre comme on
entend une souffrance et pourquoi la
sienne serait moins crédible qu'une
autre je vous demande simplement de
considérer que cet homme a pu souffrir
jusqu'à ce qu'il soit rapporté la preuve
inverse et sur moix parce que moix vous
faites linverse alors m est-ce que vous
avez les preuves de ce que vous dites
parce que c'est ça bouge si vous
attaquez la famille de yann moix et vous
avez des preuves mais nous on quelles
preuves peut-on avoir quelle preuve que
tout rapporter à vos claviers
nous allons phoques et des témoins de
ces départs n'ont pas encore là on parle
de choses et moi oui apporterons les
preuves de ce qu'ils ont tant que vous
n'avez pas regardé
ils ont du mal à lâcher excusez moi nous
ne sommes pas magicien nous sommes
réjouis nous avons des preuves nous
allons convoquer les jo qui peuvent
rappaz vous n'allez pas chercher en
parlant de témoin on a on a derrière
exprès de l'ami d'enfance réellement ils
nous ont regardé ce qu'il dit selon des
preuves plus matérielles mais la logique
à ses souffrances en garde est tellement
dans le secret autour de cette
souffrance
ouais je pense que ça peut très mal
tourner et je pense qu'il est un
survivant d'une période qui était une
guerre pour lui un surveillant d'une
guerre et qui n'est pas encore
totalement terminée la paix n'est pas
fait et aujourd'hui il est un peu
l'historien de son propre combat coin
géraldine maillet que m c'est pas beau
ultime est ce que vous pensez pas comme
bhl que finalement il a tout orchestré
inconsciemment ou leur serment mais à
dire qu'en fait il voulait il fallait
libérer des foules livre et il savait en
ou en écrivant ce livre que ça allait
ouvrir la boîte de pandore et que
effectivement y aurait tout ce
déferlement et médiatique et familiale
et que tout allait sortir et que enfin
ils allaient pouvoir être mam sont et je
croyais je crois qu'inconsciemment il y
est allé je voulais dit tout à l'heure
vers ça en sachant que d'autres
révélations à les suivre et ce chantage
exercé par son frère qui veut absolument
sortir ses dessins il existe et le
chantage coopérer par les personnes
infréquentable qu'il a fréquenté dans sa
jeunesse il existe depuis toutes ces
années
donc il savait les avaient pas à l'école
et les jeux soient extrêmement classe et
bab aussi dans les autres les avait pas
ce confrère les avait eu d'accord
benjamin castaldi
j'irai au bout je voudrais répondre
c'est difficile mais au bout et donc il
savait qu'il allait qu'il allait devoir
se confond pas ça c'était le prix de sa
liberté
est ce qu'il pensait que c'était aux
prix d'être le seul type j'ai été
tabassé dans sa jeune et à l'asie où
tout le monde se tord is c'est pas grave
ça ne reste pas moins vrai et où tout le
monde soit d'horizon moi je pense qu'ils
m'en le mec s'est pris des tartes a été
écrasée physiquement et c'est le
saxophone
je ne sais pas pourquoi mais il savait
mener votre métier vous êtes très doué
mais la volonté de nier cette violence
mais est ce que votre relation
c'est plus de dévoiler les preuves ap
les abords sud et déjà la banque postale
déroule
oui c'est notre devoir moi j'en
retiendrai dit rémy sur le livre on est
bon qu'il fait une révélation
rappelez-vous fait récemment elle a fait
un livre la consommation ont expliqué ce
qu'ils avaient vécu dans son enfance qui
a fait un énorme article ce sont ses
parents sa mère son frère qui l'ont
accueilli à quelle montée moi j'ai envie
de dire honnêtement sûr c'était sur
cette expérience là ce qui après il ya
plein de débat mais sur le livre
laissées long - le crédit d'avoir vécu
ça honnêtement mais combien j'aurais eu
cette question combien de femmes violées
ont bien traitée de [ __ ] un moment
donné pourquoi pourquoi il ya deux mois
que serait le seul type en france
laquelle on ôte la qualité du style mais
on veut savoir pourquoi quand vous êtes
accusé de viol vous accuser quelqu'un de
bien que c'est pas forcément là il
accuse ses propres propos à l'endroit tu
sais faire c'est vous les enfants
tabasser par leurs parents la planète
souffrent cette valeur en tant que je
n'ai pas écrit un bouquin pour avoir le
droit d'acheter cette fois dans le nord
ouest je vous dis les rives selon lui
donne même pas si c'est moi et moi
moi je suis avocat vous devez entendre
une souffrance et la contester sans
aucun élément juste pour ça ça gueule
juste parce que vous rêvez ya quand même
quelque chose qui me dérange beaucoup ce
sera ma dernière intervention que c'est
que j'ai l'impression que s'agissant de
yann moix
on ne veut pas la justice mon voeu la
vengeance contre lui non au nom de cela
ce que c'est un chronique mise en
violant qui peut l'être beaucoup et j'ai
l'impression que les gens disent bien
fait pour sa gueule qui soit le nous qui
le disent la mélodie en justice contre m
je veux ya deux mois que j'ai compris il
ya deux mois au centre yann moix après
il veut quelque chose il veut simplement
qu'on peut dire que yann moix est aussi
un être humain il est un écrivain on n'a
pas le beau coup il est aussi un être
humain respecter l'écrivain respecter
avant tout être humain